[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de France 24 es un artista que
se destaca por su versatilidad su
capacidad para fusionar los estilos de
música y su exploración de los sonidos
antidianos y caribeños proyecto tras
proyecto un cantautor dominicano
radicado en Colombia ganador de tres
premios Grammys Latinos Y qué estreno
hace unos meses su cuarto disco camino
al sol
[Música]
y estoy muy feliz de recibirlo en
nuestro estudio Vicente Muchas gracias
por aceptar nuestra invitación en
francés 24 Hola hola feliz de estar aquí
por primera vez Bueno
tu último proyecto camino al sol nació
durante la pandemia y lo describes como
un viaje introspectivo pero hacia la
sanación tal como en sus temas como en
su mismo proceso de creación cómo lo
viviste bueno en primer lugar fue un
disco que nació en plena pandemia y se
nutre de todo
esas situaciones que vivimos
nosotros durante esa época
cuestionamiento de la vida una
introspección y y saber Hacia dónde
vamos de dónde venimos y creo que fue un
reflejo directo de eso
tuve la suerte de conocer a Richard
Blair que es un traductor inglés que
tiene mucho tiempo radicado aquí en
Colombia y con él empezamos a darle
forma
al disco es un disco que
se aleja un poquito de lo que venía
haciendo venía haciendo música
dominicana caribeña bachata merengue
también desde una búsqueda y una
investigación pero en este caso quise
trabajar más con los instrumentos de
Cuerda africanos del norte de África el
salam de la región de de mal y por ahí
el arpa de tíope también y con esa con
esa estética encontrar un vocabulario y
un lenguaje además de lo que tú dices
encontrar en la música una herramienta
también de sanación y de encontrar
tranquilidad de meditación de
introspección como dije ahorita Bueno
entonces vamos a escuchar para ver todo
esto un fragmento de desvanecer una de
estas cinco canciones
[Música]
Vicente como lo hemos visto entonces con
esta canción desvanecer no hiciste
videoclips
para acompañar sus canciones elegiste
animación porque porque eso yo creo que
respondía mucho a la manera en que
hicimos la música no se trataba como de
la persona sino como del trabajo en
conjunto
Y sí la verdad desde hace un tiempo
trato de no salir mucho en mis vídeos no
sé por qué me da un poco de trabajo de
pena que voy a decir bueno y
cinco canciones un ep en una época donde
hay muchos artistas que hablan de la
dificultad de elegir las canciones
cuando se viene el tiempo de hacer un
álbum A qué se debe eso creo que la
misma música y el trabajo
venía muy desde
el resultado en grupo lo que sucedió en
la grabación es juntos y la misma música
trata de
devocar ciertas imágenes Entonces si lo
dejamos como a la subjetividad y otro
tema que se destaca de tu último
álbumes la investigación pero es un
propósito que ya tenías con todos tus
otros proyectos lo podemos escuchar en
la diversidad de esos instrumentos lo
pudimos leer en tus entrevistas pero
también lo muestras En tus redes
sociales en YouTube en en videos que que
muestran justamente todo este proceso de
creación con unos subtítulos además en
inglés porque empezaste con estos vídeos
con esta manera de
todo tu trabajo Bueno yo empecé con esa
esos vídeos con el disco a la mar sobre
todo porque quería que la gente
entendiera de dónde venía
mi manera de hacer bachata que venía
desde la investigación desde la búsqueda
no es solamente
decidir en un momento ser bachata con lo
cual Hay ciertos instrumentos o ciertos
procesos que que en la grabación se
llevaron a cabo que a mí me interesaba
que la gente lo viviera conmigo
desde que hice ese Primero me di cuenta
que que era una herramienta importante
para que la gente entendiera el universo
que existe alrededor de la grabaciones
de mi disco desde la preproducción de
conseguir instrumentos de diferente
parte del mundo hasta allá la parte
final de mezcla y de masterización y
justamente eso es importante para ti
demostrar toda la
solicitud del trabajo y también Mostrar
hacer descubrir tal vez esos
instrumentos que mucha gente no había
visto antes Sí además que siento que
de lo que a mí misma Me divierte o sea
poder tener la posibilidad de de
experimentar con instrumentos
que generen nuevas texturas Entonces sí
me doy cuenta que la gente lo disfruta
conmigo cuando ve ese proceso sucede
Bueno este proceso lo vamos a escuchar
justamente con con un estado de bachata
en Kingston una de las canciones del
álbum
y ganadora del Grammy latinoa mejor
canción tropical en 2017
ayer y hoy
y ahora recuerdo esa noche
y yo me muero de dolor
y me consume de a poco pensar que estoy
bailando con otro
como loco me quedé esperando el humo de
sudo que él se perdió por bailar de tan
lejos
y como loco me quedé frenando que no
pude arrebatarme ese beso
Vicente vives en Bogotá la capital
colombiana desde hace mucho tiempo ya
nos puedes contar un poquito más tu
relación con esta ciudad con este país y
como influencia tu música Bueno yo tengo
nueve años ya viviendo aquí en Bogotá
vine por primera vez abriendo la gira de
Juan Luis Guerra la gira de la travesía
y luego a partir de ahí empecé a
a darme a conocer sobre todo en Bogotá y
Medellín luego viene a ser un par de
conciertos pequeños
y la última vez que vine vine a una a un
mercado musical que se llama el circular
en Medellín y luego venía a quedarme un
par de semanas más hacer un par de
conciertos y la verdad que
esos conciertos eran dos Se volvieron
como 10 o 12 duré dos meses aquí y luego
llegué a Santo Domingo y me planteé la
idea de venir a vivir aquí había hecho
también muy buenos amigos de la música
en ese en ese momento
y había una escena súper
bonita emergiendo aquí Entonces nada
pensé venir tal vez un año o dos y llevo
ya nueve años
eso pasa muchas veces con mucha gente y
hablando de justamente tu próxima fecha
de concierto es el 2 de diciembre en el
barrio Center cómo te sientes con esta
gira Y qué tal ha recibido el público
tus nuevas canciones bueno ha sido una
gira larga tenemos ya casi todo el año
tocando hemos estado en España tuvimos
Madrid en Barcelona
estuvimos en Puerto Rico en Costa Rica
también haciendo un Sinfónico
estuvimos también en República
Dominicana en mi hogar y ahora Cerramos
el
el año con concierto aquí en Bogotá este
2 de diciembre en el royal Center Es
realmente un concierto súper súper
bailable incluimos alguna canciones de
camino al sol pero la idea de que sea un
concierto que le dé la entrada a la
Navidad y a las fiestas de diciembre
básicamente Muchas gracias Vicente
García por acompañarnos en francés 24 y
además de esta fecha del 2 de diciembre
en Bogotá vas a tocar también el 28 de
enero en Costa Rica y el 17 de febrero
en Santo Domingo en formatos Sinfónico Y
entonces para tener una idea Nos
despedimos con la versión sinfónica de
alamar junto a la orquesta filarmónica
de Bogotá Gracias a ustedes por su
confianza y sigan con nosotros hay más
cultura en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]
para solucionaremos corazón
[Aplausos]
[Música]
que se enciende con tu amor
[Aplausos]